[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we bring in
dominic wilkins the hall of famer the
hawks vice president
of basketball and uh 26 close to 27
000 points when it was all said and done
he's broadcasting the hawks playoff
games for
bally sports and he joins us now nick
good morning how you feeling
good how are you doing i'm doing okay um
were you ever told
how your parents came up with dominique
as your name
uh yeah actually my dad was in the
military
um he was in the army for 26 years
but anyway i was born and sober in
france right outside of paris
and we had a nanny who who named me and
basically she said to my mom look at
little dominique
she said that's not his name she said
well it should be and
my mom said okay it changed his name to
little dominique
really but actually dominique is my
middle name my first name is
jacques dominic wow so you certainly
have the french influence there
yeah i do i do can't speak the lick of
it but
i was wondering if we came up with a uh
a nine foot rim
and had you and jordan do a dunk contest
right now
it would be the greatest nine foot duck
contest
ever because we don't have to jump as
high
anymore so that would be fun actually
but
i you know i talked to dr jay about
dunking he said that he can still dunk
he said it's
it's not going up it's coming down that
hurts so much
you know i say that all the time you
know it is not the going up that
that hurts coming down is what's going
to kill you you know but
you know i can still dunk as well at
right age of 61.
but uh you know you gonna have some
aches and pains later on though
did you ever feel sorry for when you
dunked on somebody
uh not an ounce and that was the most
exhilarating feeling that you could ever
have especially when you do it
you dunk on big guys big guys where it
seemed like to
get you charged up after you make a
great play like that give me the guy you
dunked on and you just said man that is
so good
well you know from quite a few but
i would say guys like like
joining guys like bob lanier who didn't
speak to me for nine years after
you know robert parish and guys like
that i mean i just really got me off
i was done from bigger guys well you
dunked on bird didn't you a few times
a few times a few times you know
probably shouldn't have jumped
well i you can tell when guys go up to
block a dunk
or contest it and then they start to go
up and they realize i'm starting to come
down and you're still going up
this is going to end well you've seen
those situations many times you know
where you got the great high flyers and
you bought them challenging when you get
there you like
uh oh i'm in trouble and you know when
you got the great high flies man they
have the ability to hang in there a
little bit longer than others
it's just a beautiful thing to watch we
brought up your brother the other day
when he was labeled the jordan stopper
and
i felt bad for your brother because
you knew that was going to make michael
man when
you oh you're the jordan stopper huh you
know what i called my brother
when he said that and i said so i said
what are you doing know i said you don't
want to awaken a sleeping giant are you
crazy
and uh he said hey he put on his pants
like i do i said girl
joe you know if you're a good defensive
player you don't have to talk about it
man you don't want to get him
riled up i think he averaged like 40 in
that series
[Laughter]
yeah whenever there was this guy's the
next jordan or this guy is the jordan
stopper i went
this isn't going to go well it's just
it's not it's not
and i used to love when guys talk trash
you know and say things because i would
be so jacked up and ready to play
against that
guy he was gonna have a long night the
atmosphere at the garden last night like
you played
at the boston garden you know in those
playoff games with a sudden like
just like that environment what is that
like to play in an
environment when you know the opposing
team hates you
there's no better environment than those
hostile
environments as an opponent on your
court
that's what basketball is all about
that's what competing is all about
i embrace it and it really it's a
compliment to you as an individual
when fans boo you and and and try to
come after you it's a it's a compliment
you
could because they know how good you are
and that's the thing that happened to
trey young and you know i said to you
know the last couple days
that's just the respect they have from
if they didn't respect them they
wouldn't say anything
but also what is he 20 years of age i
mean imagine
you're 20. yeah i mean nick you're 20
years of age you're in the garden
they're saying
f you trey young i mean
wow it's a bit much i will say that
but at the same time uh when you kick
somebody's
ass they don't chant as much
you know then at the end of the day you
know when the series are with those same
fans so you know what
we have to give him his respect and his
it is due because
he came to play and so he's one of those
young superstars that's embrace it don't
bother him
you know he loves it matter of fact so
and that's what great players do that
was
really the good and great they embrace
that
because that's what competing is all
about do you recognize today's nba
oh yes of course yes you know and look
we all play in a different time
you know when i hate when people get to
comparing oh this area is better that
air is better
you know you know this air is more
talented and it's just ridiculous when i
hear that stuff you know i'd say if you
people do their history go back
you know when some of the greatest
players ever play this game were playing
you know it was a knockout drag out type
of game where guys just went at each
other it was
very competitive and so we've had our
time you know it's these guys times
and so only thing i hate is when they
try to discredit us
to prove a point yeah i just
wonder who would have benefited the most
in today's rules
who you played with i wish that nobody
couldn't touch me
you know back when i played you know i
was getting 28 30 plus
in handcheck error you know and people
ask me i was like oh what would you ever
i said i don't know
if you couldn't touch me i can tell you
to be over 35 again
you know because i love the physical
contact so the fact that
they can't touch you like that anymore
it definitely would
be beneficial to me what's the best
performance you ever witnessed
the best performance i ever witnessed a
part of was against michael jordan
and i never had a player to do this
before i think i had 57
in atlanta we go back to chicago weeks
later
and i remember michael jordan walks in
our locker room
before the game we in suit and time
haven't gotten dressed there he walks in
our locker room
and i'm like what the hell is he doing
you know
so i'm thinking maybe going to the
training room or something so he walks
by me
he walks by kevin willis and he gets to
randy with me and he slaps someone
behind he said
lace them up it's going to be a long
night and turn and walked out
and i'm in shock i'm like did he just
and i didn't know what to say i said
well you tell that so-and-so scotty pick
my
kick i didn't know what to say
he had 60.
and but you know even though he had 60s
the way he had it
you know it was the electric man i mean
it was it was incredible
to witness you know what he was though
nick when we see kobe kobe
was a volume shooter mike was pretty
economical like
he he he made the most of his
possessions and his shots
he was so efficient as well as being an
assassin a killer
out there on the floor and he wanted to
basically take your heart with every
possession
that's who he was i mean he wasn't a guy
without that make friends
my greatest battles that i've had was
against michael michael and i are
probably the only ones
in the history i mean i would say
throughout our career through our whole
career we were the only two
as foes to average over 30 against one
another for a career
i mean that's how competitive it was do
you think we're headed for uh
lakers nets
i wouldn't i wouldn't go that far as of
yet you know because
lakers still got to get by phoenix even
though home court has swung back into
the lakers favor
it's going to be a good i think that's
still going to be good it all depends on
if
chris paul is healthy if he's not
healthy i think it'd be tough for
phoenix
yeah i really do i mean because you know
you got lebron you got a.d
over there long as you got those two
guys healthy and playing the way they
did the other night
and still i think it'd be tough to beat
the lakers you okay with these guys
joining teams
in these super teams well that's the way
it is now
that's where it is now you know the
thing is that when we played i always
wanted to try to win for this city
in atlanta and only way i figured that i
can measure my greatness
is to play against the greatest players
so now none of us wanted to
to join teams if it happened it happened
but we didn't
you know seek teams out to because you
couldn't do it in those days anyway
not like that things have changed
players have more control now
well i think one of the first times i
remember was when moses malone joined dr
j in philadelphia
and that felt like a a super team i mean
they already had a talented team but
he i think he was a free agent and he
joined the 76ers with doc
but it wasn't like you know it was you
know the
public knowledge that he might be going
here going there it just happened with
you know a guy end up in a situation
team had enough money you know they've
moved another player
the next thing you know moses malone is
still out there hadn't signed
or would he hadn't decided he wasn't
deciding with anybody yet
but when opportunity came up to go to
philly you know he went to philly
and yeah they had a great team but yeah
they became a super team when he came
there
do you still hold a grudge against
anybody
you know no i held grudges when i played
against guys
but and i didn't like certain guys but
now i want to talk to those guys about
the way no i take that back certain guys
you know some guys like still can't
stand but give me a give me a couple of
names you think you you don't like well
well guys that we you know we hate each
other and we the funny thing is we end
up playing together
uh for a year and that was chuck person
man we fought all the time
i mean fist fights we've had and now i
end up on the team when i'm like i don't
understand what a guy i absolutely
cannot stand
you know but
after you retire man like come along and
i up to the time
we had had conversations we didn't talk
together for over 21 years
we really didn't from the time he played
the time years after retiring
and i remember we went to an event and i
cracked some corny joke and call malone
family was sitting on one side my family
was sitting other side it's a nick
i didn't know you that funny and we said
yeah we thought you were a-ho
and call him alone myself and clyde
director we're like brothers now
we're we're close we're so close man
because we cherish the times
and that we competed and played against
one you know so we we live for those
conversations
were you okay with patrick ewing oh pat
was a very close friend of mine as well
uh i love patrick you and spear loved
him as
as a player respected him a lot and even
to this day
you know pat and i you know we we're
very close friends yeah
well he had that demeanor on the floor
though he had a oh he had
head attitude yeah yeah that's but that
was the respect that we have on them
it was an unspoken thing that we didn't
have to speak to one another we didn't
have to shake hands you know
we knew what we were here for well you
have to you have to hate bill lane beer
uh yeah
[Laughter]
remember i think everybody in the league
hated that that's true
they did but but the funny thing is man
i
you know i talk to my horn these days
man and we laugh about
that stuff now and you know if you if
you talk to both of those guys
they're really big teddy bears they
really are you know
but when you put them between the lines
they
you know it's like their whole demeanor
it changes and that's what
competitiveness
does you know but you know those guys
was
there was some tough rugged you know
nasty guys
you know but you know i remember lambeau
took me out of the air one time we had
we i jumped up i'm swinging and you know
punches being thrown after the game i
see him
at a restaurant slash lounge hey nick
how you doing
like do you remember you just took me
out of there
you know you forgot but
but lane beer knew his job like he
he kind of he's like an actor you know
this guy shows up then becomes a
character and then when he's done
then he walks off and then he's
different yeah that's what
that's who lambeau was you know it was
like an actor in a sense but
his demeanor and his attitude you know
as far as his focus of the game was bar
none some of the
most focused guys i've ever seen i mean
they were there for one reason to take
your heart
and uh it was something to to to
experience and and compete against but
it made it fun
it's great to catch up with you as
always nick have fun the rest of this
series should be pretty spirited and uh
thanks for joining us
thanks pat good to see you man that's uh
dominique wilkins the uh hall of famer
the hawks vice president of basketball
and he's
working the hawks playoff games for
valley sports